parce que le digital est un vrai
tremplin de la relation publique et du
développement commercial
la cci a décidé de proposer une séance
sur le numérique à une centaine
d'entrepreneurs le but les encourager à
prendre cette voie sont des sessions
d'information avait une forme de
conférences et de tables rondes autour
de la relation et de l'expérience client
à l'heure du digital donc nous espérons
pouvoir leur communiquer un maximum
d'informations sur la nécessaire
transformation de l'entreprise via le
digital afin de les accompagner à
développer leur activité et leur réseau
commercial
en effet lorsque l'on compare avec nos
voisins européens en plus de 80% des
entreprises par exemple en angleterre et
en allemagne sont équipés d'internet
voire plus de 90 % pour les pme
finlandaise il ya un retard
tout simplement parce que les
entreprises et les entrepreneurs pas
tous mais un certain nombre n'ont pas
encore saisi les opportunités que
peuvent apporter de numérique et quand
je parle des opportunités c'est les
opportunités business le numérique peut
accompagner la transformation économique
d'une entreprise est trop souvent les
entrepreneurs les artisans les
commerçants ne le savent pas ou n'ont
pas conscience de l'avantagé du
numérique dans la transformation
économique
et quand je parle de transformation
économique ces commandes numériques paul
oracle aura mené du chiffre d'affaires
additionnel des contacts et du coup
remplir les carnets de commandes selon
des études lorsqu'une entreprise prend
la voie du numérique à l'augmenter son
chiffre d'affaires de 50 % la cci
organisera plusieurs événements tout au
long de l'année